all right so you've seen Ultra wide
monitors and you've seen curve monitors
but have you
seen the ultra wide that turns into a
curved monitor so this thing is called
the Zenon Flex it's made by Corsair it's
a 45 in 240 HZ 1440p OLED gaming Monitor
and it looks pretty reasonable just
sitting on a desk but it's got these
handles at the bottom and on the sides
that give away that it's really a weird
$2,000 hybrid monitor so this bottom
handle is just for tilt so you can kind
of tilt it up like this or tilt it back
down almost with one hand cuz the base
is pretty heavy but then these side
handles here let you move it back to
flat or let you curve it in up to its
maximum of 800 R you heard the click but
also you could stop it halfway for a
subtle curve if you want to these
handles also slide back behind the
monitor to be hidden so no one ever has
to know that your fancy $2,000 monitor
is more flexible than most